Dès que je parle, les interruptions commencent
les gens parlent en même temps que moi à maintes reprises.
Certaines de mes idées sont écartées
puis évoquées par quelqu'un d'autre et soutenues.
J'étais la seule femme dans cette pièce.
J'aurais eu besoin d'un allié.
De tels comportements et tendances, chaque jour, à maintes reprises,
vous accablent.
Très vite, je n'ai plus eu d'énergie.
Lors d'un mauvais moment, j'ai lu un article
sur la culture organisationnelle toxique et les micro-agressions.
Les micro-agressions -- Au quotidien, les offenses, les insultes,
la communication verbale et non-verbale négative,
intentionnelle ou non,
qui entrave votre capacité à bien faire votre travail.
Cela semblait familier.
J'ai commencé à réaliser que je ne défaillais pas.
La culture autour de moi me faisait défaut.
Et je n'étais pas seule.
De tels comportements et tendances
nuisent au quotidien au travail aux personnes sous-représentées
issues de tous les milieux.
Cela a un réel impact
sur nos collègues, nos entreprises
et notre capacité d'innovation collective.
Dans l'industrie technologique, nous voulons des solutions rapides.
Mais il n'y a pas de baguette magique pour corriger la diversité et l'inclusion.
Le changement se produit une personne à la fois,
un geste à la fois, un mot à la fois.
Nous commettons une erreur en voyant la diversité et l'inclusion
comme un projet connexe sur lequel les gens de la diversité travaillent,
plutôt qu'un travail en nous que nous devons réaliser ensemble.
Ce travail commence
en désapprenant ce que nous savons sur la réussite et les opportunités.
Toute notre vie, on nous a dit
qu'en travaillant dur, cela payerait,
nous aurions ce que nous mériterions, nous vivrions notre rêve.
Cela n'est pas vrai pour tout le monde.
Certains doivent travailler dix fois plus dur
pour arriver à la même chose
du fait des nombreux obstacles que la société place devant eux.
Votre sexe, votre race, votre ethnicité,
votre religion, votre handicap, votre orientation sexuelle,
votre classe, votre géographie,
tout cela peut vous donner plus ou moins d'opportunités pour réussir.
C'est là que les alliés entrent en jeu.
Être un allié, c'est comprendre le déséquilibre en termes d'opportunités
et travailler pour arranger cela.
Être un allié, c'est voir vraiment la personne à nos côtés.
Et la personne qui n'est pas là, qui devrait se tenir à nos côtés.
Tout d'abord savoir ce qu'elle traverse.
Ensuite, l'aider à réussir et à s'épanouir avec nous.
En travaillant ensemble pour des équipes plus diversifiées et inclusives,
les données montrent que nous serons plus innovants, productifs et rentables.
Qui est un allié ?
Nous le sommes tous.
Nous pouvons tous être des alliés.
En tant que femme blanche et cisgenre aux États-Unis,
je suis privilégiée de bien des façons.
De d'autres façons, je ne le suis pas.
Je travaille dur chaque jour
pour être une alliée pour ceux moins privilégiés que moi.
Et j'ai toujours besoin d'alliés.
Dans l'industrie technologique, comme dans beaucoup d'industries,
beaucoup de gens sont sous-représentés
ou font face à des obstacles et de la discrimination.
Les femmes, les gens non binaires --
ceux qui ne se considèrent pas nécessairement homme ou femme --
les minorités raciales et ethniques,
les LGBTQIA, les gens atteints de handicap, les vétérans,
quiconque ayant plus de 35 ans.
(Rires)
Nous avons un parti pris pour la jeunesse dans l'industrie technologique.
Et dans beaucoup d'autres.
Il y a toujours quelqu'un moins privilégié que vous.
Sur cette scène, dans cette pièce,
dans votre entreprise, dans votre équipe, dans votre ville ou commune.
Les gens sont des alliés pour différentes raisons.
Trouvez la vôtre.
Ce peut être pour les affaires,
d'après les données, des équipes diversifiées et inclusives
seront plus productives, rentables et innovatrices.
Ce peut être pour l'équité et la justice sociale.
Car nous avons un long historique d'oppression et d'inégalité
sur lequel nous devons travailler ensemble.
Ou peut-être pour vos enfants,
afin que vos enfants grandissent et jouissent de l'égalité des chances
et qu'ils soient ensuite à l'origine de l'égalité des chances pour d'autres.
Trouvez votre raison.
Pour moi, ce sont les trois.
Trouvez votre raison et soyez là pour quelqu'un qui a besoin de vous.
En tant qu'allié, que pouvez-vous faire ?
Commencez par ne pas causer de préjudice.
C'est notre rôle d'alliés de savoir ce que sont les micro-agressions
et de ne pas les perpétrer.
C'est notre rôle d'alliés d'écouter, d'apprendre,
de désapprendre et de réapprendre,
de faire des erreurs et de continuer à apprendre.
Accordez-moi pleinement votre attention.
Fermez vos ordinateurs,
posez vos téléphones et prêtez attention.
Si quelqu'un est nouveau, la seule personne ainsi dans la pièce
ou s'il est nerveux,
cela fera une grand différence dans leur comportement.
N'interrompez pas.
Les gens sous-représentés ont plus de risques d'être interrompus.
Prenez du recul et écoutez.
Répétez et attribuez.
Si j'ai une super idée,
répétez mon idée et attribuez-la moi, nous réussirons ensemble.
Apprenez le langage dont je me sers pour décrire mon identité.
Sachez prononcer mon nom.
Connaissez mes pronoms -- il, elle, iel.
Connaissez le langage dont je me sers
pour décrire mon handicap, mon ethnicité, ma religion.
Cela compte vraiment pour les gens alors si vous ne savez pas, demandez.
Écoutez et apprenez.
Un cadre m'a dit récemment qu'après avoir été allié de son équipe,
toute l'équipe a normalisé le fait de se reprendre, eux et les autres,
après avoir interrompu quelqu'un.
« Désolé, je t'interromps, continue. »
« Hey, elle a une super idée, écoutons. »
Deux : faites de petits gestes pour défendre les gens sous-représentés.
Intervenez, vous pouvez changer la dynamique du pouvoir.
Si vous voyez que quelqu'un est la seule personne ainsi dans la pièce
et qu'il est dénigré, interrompu,
faites quelque chose, dites quelque chose.
Invitez les gens sous-représentés à parler.
Refusez les discussions sans intervenants sous-représentés.
Recommandez quelqu'un pour un poste
et encouragez-le à prendre ce poste et saisir de nouvelles opportunités.
Ceci est très important : aidez à normaliser le fait d'être un allié.
Si vous êtes quelqu'un de privilégié,
il est plus facile pour vous de promouvoir les alliés.
Utilisez ce privilège pour provoquer du changement.
Trois : changez considérablement la vie de quelqu'un.
Soyez là pour quelqu'un au long de sa carrière.
Soyez son mentor ou son parrain,
donnez-lui des opportunités durant sa croissance.
Soyez bénévole -- pour un programme STIM au service des jeunes en difficulté.
Rendez votre équipe plus diversifiée et inclusive.
Engagez-vous à provoquer du changement ici.
Que vous et votre équipe preniez la responsabilité
de provoquer le changement.
Finalement,
aidez à promouvoir le changement dans toute l'entreprise.
Quand on apprend aux employés à être des alliés,
les programmes de diversité et d'inclusion sont plus soutenus.
Vous et moi pouvons être alliés,
que ce soit au travail ou en dehors.
J'ai récemment réalisé
que j'éprouvais une honte et une peur persistantes
depuis ce moment dans ma carrière où je me suis sentie complètement seule,
exclue et non soutenue.
Il y a des millions de personnes, comme moi, qui ressentent cela.
Cela ne coûte pas grand chose d'être là pour les autres.
Quand nous sommes là pour les autres, pour les soutenir,
nous réussissons ensemble.
Quand nous réussissons, nous créons de meilleures équipes,
de meilleurs produits et de meilleures entreprises.
Être un allié est formidable.
Essayez-le.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)